Okay. Oh, here we are.
>> Oh, here we go.
>> All right.
>> Yeah,
>> just a moment.
>> He meant July, August.
>> There was no
>> We are ready to go.
>> Alex.
>> Okay. Welcome to the September 10, 2025
full board meeting of Manhattan
Community Board 6. My name is Sandy McKe
and I'm the chair of CB6. This meeting
is called to order at 7:05 p.m. Tonight
we are joined by first vice chair John
Keller, district manager Jesus Perez,
assistant district manager Brendan
Berth, and community coordinator Brian
Laughaferty. New York New York state law
requires all community board members who
are not able to attend the meeting in
person to have their cameras on and
their first and last names displayed
from the time the meeting is called to
order until the time the meeting is
adjourned. So, welcome back everyone.
Hope you had a good summer break. Um,
and now a reminder of how we conduct our
meetings. Do not speak until granted the
floor. Please raise your hand and wait
for me to recognize you. It is important
that only one person speaks at a time so
that members of the public watching at
home can understand what is being said.
You will be given a microphone if you
are recognized to speak. The chat
function should not be used for CB6
business or questions about agenda
topics. Members of the public, if you
wish to give remarks during the public
session and have not already registered
by filling out a form, you can register
to speak in the public session on Zoom
by using the Q&A feature and posting
your name, your affiliation, and what
specific topic you wish to speak about.
Or if you are here in person and want to
speak in the public session, you need to
fill out our public speaker form, which
is near the signins for the CB6
newsletter. This needs to be done by
7:15.
The agenda for tonight's meeting was
distributed ahead of time by the board
office, was posted online, and appears
on the screen before you. If there is no
objection, we will adopt the agenda as
stated. Board members, if you object to
adopting the agenda, you may raise your
hand.
Seeing no objections, the agenda for
tonight's meeting is adopted.
Jesus will now take attendance.
All right,
welcome back everyone.
Uh, when I call your name, please
indicate that you are present.
>> Tanya Aras,
>> present via Zoom.
>> Thank you. And Brendan, just FYI, it
sounds like the sound is coming from
your laptop, not from the owl.
>> Yeah, I'll work on troubleshooting that.
>> Thank you. Kifified.
Kalified.
I don't hear anything. Uh, Neil Barkley,
>> present.
>> Thank you.
Marty Barrett,
>> thank you. Elie Barroso,
>> thank you. Daniel Bernstein,
>> present.
>> Thank you. Liz Burr, thank you. Jim
Collins is absent.
>> Stu Desert.
>> Thank you. B. Disman,
>> present.
>> Thank you.
All right. Amaya Donahghue.
Thank you. Robert Farfan,
>> present.
>> Thank you. Barack Freriedman,
>> Thank you. Jason Fromitz,
>> present.
>> Thank you. Eric Goldberg,
>> Thank you. Justin Goldberg is absent.
Gloria Hage.
>> Thank you. Rabia is absent.
Paige judge.
Paige judge
her.
>> I don't hear anyone for Paige. Uh Rupul
Kakad
>> here.
>> Thank you. John Keller
>> present.
>> Thank you. Kate Kennedy
>> Thank you. Katie Landa
>> present.
>> Okay. Thank you. Sandra Ltoff
>> Thank you. Anton Malner,
>> present.
>> Thank you. Sandy McKe,
>> Thank you. Alec Milit,
>> present. Thank you. Rich Mintz.
Rich Mintz.
>> I don't hear anyone. We'll move on.
Kevin O'Keefe
>> present.
>> Thank you. Rashma Patel.
Reshma Patel.
>> Don't see her.
>> Okay, move on. Steve Perez,
Steve Perez.
I don't hear anything. Will Perry
>> present.
>> Thank you. Omar Careshi,
>> Thank you. Mariam Ralph
>> here.
>> Thank you. Michael Anne Row.
Michael Anne Row.
I don't hear anything. We'll move on.
Larry Sh
is absent. An Seligman
>> here.
>> Thank you. Sandro Sherrod
>> Thank you.
>> Bubin Sadiki
>> present.
>> Thank you.
Letty Simon,
>> I believe I heard her. She's
>> here. Yeah.
>> Yes, she's here.
>> Yeah, Letty is here. Okay.
Uh Mark Thompson
is not is absent. Okay.
Uh Gabe Tzo.
>> Thank you.
Uh Capillo
>> present.
>> Thank you. James Vera is absent.
>> Jerry Weinstein is absent. Sarah
Whittington
>> present.
>> Thank you. David Woods
>> here by Zoom.
Okay, thank you.
>> She is out
>> here.
>> Thank you.
>> All right, with
28 members Julie present,
uh we do have
>> our elected officials sent in their
reports ahead of time and they are
compiled on the CB6 website. The link to
the reports was sent out ahead of time
and for your convenience can be found in
the chat on Zoom or by going to our our
website's page for full board meetings.
I will call on each of the elected
officials who have RSVPd so they can
take questions from CB6 members and the
public about their presubmitted reports.
Each elected official will be able to
field questions. And if there are no
questions, we will move to the next
elected official on our list. If the
elected official has t has a
time-sensitive matter to report on that
didn't make it into their presubmitted
report, they will have three minutes to
do so. Uh, first on our list, we have
um, Senator Krueger. Welcome.
>> Good evening, everyone. Thank you for
allowing me to be here with you. And I
gather I'm not supposed to present. I'm
just supposed to let you um, ask
questions, which I'm always happy to
answer. We did a very detailed update
for the community just about a week ago.
Um trying to keep us up to date with all
the changes from the Trump
administration and the impacts on us and
so many things happening. Um I guess one
thing I didn't put in that document and
I'll stop there is I am actually not one
of the New Yorkers running for Congress
Congress since Jerry Nler has announced
that he is not going to run again. So
just if that's one of your questions, I
can just answer that for you. Not me.
I'm sticking around in the state senate
till you fire me. And now I'm happy to
answer questions.
>> Are there any are there any questions
for the senator?
>> And if there's anything else you want to
tell us, we're happy to hear. Well, I
guess the one thing I would point out
because of the Supreme Court decision
yesterday on ISIS powers to collect up
people under very strange circumstances,
including if they seem to speak with an
accent or do not have white skin.
I'm telling people, one, make sure
you're always carrying your documents
with you, no matter where you're going,
um to show that you have status to be
here in this country. never leave home
without it frankly now which is
disturbing but I think it's just an
honest analysis and since apparently
they're also concerned about people who
are speaking another language I'm really
bad at other languages but I'm going to
practice a few sentences so that when
they stop me I speak non-English and see
what happens to me I'll stop there
>> any any other questions for the senator
>> right thank thank you very much
>> oh I'm sorry tomorrow We're having the
first of our senior roundts, older New
Yorkers roundts, and the theme is
actually on advocacy and what you can
do. And that also seems appropriate to
remind people of based on everyone's
conversations right now. What do we do?
So, you should have gotten that
information um in our newsletter or if
you get my emails and you're more than
welcome to uh jump on board. And of
course, I want to give a shout out to
Wendy Brennan who's here also. and who
handles pretty much all of the webinars
and older New Yorkers issues. Thank you.
Now I'll shut up. Thanks.
>> Great. Thank you so much. Um, next on
our list, we have uh Assembly Member
Alex Bores.
>> Uh, it's great to be with you. I hope
everyone had a wonderful summer. Uh I'm
going to start uh with a personal update
which is uh three weeks ago my wife and
I had our first child. Um and so Oh,
thank you. So I am I am mostly on leave
and I'm certainly avoiding indoor events
uh until my son develops an immune
system and gets vaccinated. Um, but I I
know this is the first meeting for a
while, so I did want to hop on and just
uh quickly share some updates uh and say
hi to all of you. Um, I want to start
the actual non-personal update uh with
an acknowledgment of the violence that
we saw today where we had an action of
political violence and we had a school
shooting uh happening simultaneously in
the same time zone. Um this on the heels
of a horrific attack uh in Lizen's
district uh about a month ago um on at
345 Park uh gun violence is continuing
to affect this country and while there's
a lot that we can do at the state level,
we will need federal action in order to
make a difference there. But at the
state level, um this is an update that's
been shared prior by both me and Senator
Krueger, but but I think today of all
days is worth reiterating is that the
state in the budget invested $347
million to strengthen the Office of Gun
Violence Pro uh Protection uh sorry, the
Office of Gun Violence Prevention, uh
which is especially important because
the White House Office of Gun Violence
Protection was shut down. uh and the
state needs to take a leading role in
making sure that we can keep our
citizens safe. Um I separately have
bills on uh the use of smart guns and on
banning 50 caliber weapons. Uh these are
among a package of bills that I'm hoping
we were able to take up in the next
session. Additionally, at the very end
of last session, just after your uh your
June meeting, the assembly and senate on
the same day passed my raise act uh
which uh provides comprehensive
protections on extreme risks from AI
development. Uh if signed by the
governor, it'd be the first bill in the
country to regulate this. Um, since
then, California might be jumping ahead
and trying to get that done ahead of
time, but we're in ongoing conversations
with the governor about how to get her
to yes on this bill that 84% of New
Yorkers support. In the meantime, uh,
some of the few tech titans that oppose
it just last week, uh, created a new
super PAC where they said they're going
to spend a hundred million dollars on
advocating against any AI regulation at
the state level focused on just four
states, California, Ohio, Illinois, and
of course, New York. Um, so they are
spending a lot of money to stop anything
sensible from going forward. Uh and we
think it's really important that the
governor and all elected officials here
that while New Yorkers are very pro-
innovation, uh that's not a blank check.
We need to be kept safe from some of
these aspects as well. Um lastly, uh I
want to just a few upcoming events or
services that are new in the office. Uh
first is that we're going to be hosting
another shred truck event at our
district office on October 9th uh from
9:00 a.m. to noon. uh our office again
at 353 Lexington Avenue. So uh Lexington
and 40th Street. And uh over the summer
we introduced for the first time notary
services. So we offer free notary in our
office um from 10:00 a.m. to 2:00 p.m.
Monday through Thursday. Uh bring in any
documents want you want notorized and
we're very happy to do so. Uh and with
that uh I really appreciate your time uh
and listening and happy to answer any
questions that people have.
Uh, and Seligman has a question.
>> Can you wait for the microphone, please?
Sorry, he won't hear you.
>> I'll ask the question that uh Liz
preempted.
I've also seen your name taged as a
possible
candidate for Jerry Nery. Are you
considering it?
>> Uh, I have heard that I've seen my name
mentioned as well. I have been very
humbled by people asking that question.
Uh I I am I am not ruling it out at the
moment. I'm pretty focused on my three
and a half week old son. Um but I think
that's a question to be answered in due
time.
>> Do we have any other questions for our
assembly?
>> Great. Thank you. Well, enjoy your
evening with your son and um
>> thank you.
>> Appreciate it.
>> Yeah. Uh, next we have Mackie Bentley
from Congressman Nadler's office.
>> Uh, good evening everyone. Sorry. Uh,
the only thing I want to highlight for
my report which was mentioned by Senator
Bor
is that Congressman Ner will not be
seeking reelection uh, next year. uh he
is very grateful um and humbled to be
able to serve New York's 12th
congressional district for 32 years. Um
and while he is not seeking reelection,
our office will still be here for any
federal casework issues or any community
issues and the congressman uh will be um
in office so can uh the community strong
and for these next 16 months. Uh so
that's all I wanted to highlight. I'm
happy to take any questions.
Do we have any questions for M?
Great. Thank you very much.
Uh, next we have Christian Williams from
the mayor's office.
>> Do we have Oh, it's it's Charmaine.
>> I think I saw something in the chat
saying no update. So,
>> Oh, okay.
>> So, no updates.
>> No updates from the mayor's office.
Okay. Thank you. Uh, next we have Payton
Schultis from C Senator Gonzalez's
office.
>> Hi, report but happy to take any
questions.
>> Any questions for the senator's office?
>> Okay, great.
Um, next we have Joanna Sanchez from um
um Assembly Epstein's office.
>> Hello everyone. I hope everyone enjoyed
their summer. Um, so our updates are
that we have our upcoming movies in the
park. I hope anyone uh our constituents
could join us uh there. In addition, we
have a senior legal planning workshop to
plan healthc care proxies and powers of
attorney that will be on Monday, October
20th. additional information is in um
in the newsletter and um if anyone has
any further questions or concerns I will
drop my information in the chat. Thank
you.
>> Any questions?
Great. Thank you very much.
>> Next we have Pat Hill from Council
Member P's office.
>> Good evening everyone. Hope everyone's
doing well and had a great summer. Um, I
don't have anything to add to our report
and I know it's pretty lengthy, but uh,
if anyone has any questions, please feel
free to ask.
>> Do we have any questions for the council
member?
>> No. Okay, great.
>> Thank you.
>> All right, next we have Spencer [__]
from the office of um, council district
2.
>> Hi, good evening everyone. I hope
everyone had a good summer. Uh, I also
don't have much to share other than as
you may have heard that at the end of
the month of August, council member
Rivera resigned from her seat. Um, the
council district 2 office is still open.
We still have staff in it. Uh, you can
email the same email district
2@consil.nyc.gov
for any constituent case work. We're
still going to community board uh,
meetings and we'll continue to operate
the office until the next council member
takes a seat. So happy to take any
questions, but that's all I have.
>> Do we have any questions?
All right, great. We're really moving
through our list.
>> Sorry. Um and I think we are um do we
have
Oh, do we have anyone else on our
electedance list? I know we're waiting
for um the burough president to attend
in person, I believe. Is that correct?
So when he comes we'll we'll segue back
to him. Um has anyone signed up to speak
in the public session?
>> So just hold on. Um we have two people
who've suddenly come on. Um Curtis
Young.
>> Okay.
>> From the uh public advocates office.
>> Curtis, please go ahead.
Curtis,
>> give him a second. Okay.
Good. Good evening, CB6. I just want to
say welcome back. We are looking forward
to another invigorating fall season of
community board meetings. I don't have
any additional updates. Just want to
send my greetings from the public's
office. Look forward to being there in
person next month. Thank you.
>> Hey, thank you. Do we have any questions
for the public? No. Great. Thank you
very much.
>> We have one last agency. We have Daryl
Cochran from the city's Human Rights
Commission.
>> Daryl, are you online there? Great.
>> I am. Yes. Hi. Thank you so much. Um and
it was good to see Curtis. We were uh
former members of Community Board 12 way
uptown. But um I'm with the New York
City Commission on Human Rights. We are
the city agency that protects against
discrimination. Uh we come to each
community board uh every so often. I
just wanted to uh introduce myself. I'm
the director of the Manhattan Community
Relations Team. And um our agency, if
you do not know, uh we're the agency uh
that looks to uh protect New Yorkers
against discrimination in areas of
employment, housing, uh areas of public
accommodation. We often work with
community boards uh when it comes to uh
making sure there's sidewalk uh access
if there's any bias incidents in the
community. Uh we are definitely a
resource uh for that sort of thing. And
uh our main office uh in uh in lower
Manhattan is at 22 Reed Street and you
could walk in um at any time at that
peri at uh Monday through Friday 9:30 to
4:30 I believe. And um
so you know I just want to uh let you
know that we're here as a resource for
you. If someone uh if you experience
discrimination or someone you know you
could reach out to 212416197
or you could visit our website at
nyc.gov/human
rights. So thank you so much.
>> Great. Thank you. Do we have questions?
Any questions? All right. No. Thanks
very much. I think now we are ready to
move on to the public session.
>> All right. Um the first person on the
list is Charles Coutino, uh president of
the Southern Area Community who wishes
to speak to the board on a matter uh
relating to a resolution that we've got
on a cannabis application for 998
through 1000 First Avenue. Mr. Coutino
or Dr. Coutino, I believe you have three
minutes to make your remarks. You may
begin your remarks now.
Are you there? Shouldn't be able to
unmute himself.
>> Sir, you'll have to unmute yourself.
Well, it looks like the burough
president is just joining us. So, while
we give Dr. Coutino some time to sort
out his audio issues, we will hear from
the burough president, Manhattan Burough
President.
>> Our burough president, welcome
>> so much.
>> Well, CB6 looks like I came in right on
time.
How you make an interest in this
business? I know you've heard this
before. describe that my my outrage, my
anger, my deep sorrow at the murder of
Charlie Kirk is not about politics. It's
about a an escalating cycle of political
violence which uh is a cancer which
spreads and we simply need to denounce
it. We need to stop this. We need to
stop all gun violence. We need to stop
easy access to guns in this country. We
need to resolve our differences through
peaceful means. I want to get that on
the record.
Now, can I move on to a happier topic?
Uh, I got to cut the ribbon yesterday on
a wonderful new capital project right
here at CB6. Soul One has finally opened
down by Peter Cyrus and Cove. Do you
guys know about this project? Yes, it
took 20 years. You probably had 12
hearings on it. It came out beautifully.
For those who don't know, this is right
on the water at about 23rd Street. It's
uh by this wonderful nonprofit that's
going to provide environmental education
for young people, career access, career
training, job fairs, and more uh for
adults in green technologies and the
environmental sciences. Training for
teachers and public schools to teach
environmental science all right there on
the waterfront. And the building itself
is an incredible example of resiliency.
Uh this is of course an area that flood
in the Sandy. is uh got its own solar
power so it can survive off the grid in
case there's a power outage. It uh is
elevated all the building systems can
keep operating even in the midst of the
catastrophic storm and has got many many
other beautiful features designed by a
star architect uh Bure Engel. So what a
great message for young people to see
this. So go check it out. We opened it
yesterday. Um I I got to commend uh
community states on a couple things. you
have been leading on on reinvisioning
street transportation. I know you've
doubled down on support for the 34th
Street Pathway. I'm really excited about
this. I know it wasn't easy. Uh any kind
of street redesign. A plug for that. We
we support it.
Mildly path.
And I also share this board's love of
fairies, which I see at this point an
absolutely essential piece of our
transportation network. It could be even
better. And I think you're working on
Wow, this is like now to bring you with
me to all my events, man. Awesome. You
like fairies, too. Um, I know you keep a
tight uh agenda here, so I I just want
to very I'll mention very quickly before
I wrap up. Uh I imagine the topic of
casinos are on your mind.
>> Uh pity me.
>> Yes.
>> In my burrow. Uh and of course I have I
have a seat on the the uh community
advisory council. Uh you're not going to
hear any defended state in front of me
right now because I'm playing a little
more cautiously. But I want you to know
I have heard probably from thousands of
people in community board 6 in the
surrounding areas uh overwhelming
probably 90% plus opposition. I can
tabulate it. I hear you. I've
internalized your concerns. Know that I
hear you. You come through loud and
clear. I didn't know if the board took a
position. I think you did early on.
Right. debating
>> definitely heard from board members and
I've heard from neighbors and residents
and small businesses. So message
received. I'll leave you with that. Stay
tuned. Um finally Hispanic Heritage
Month. I know we have so much to
celebrate. Uh yes indeed. And we're
doing our big annual celebration on
September 20
>> 25th
>> 25th. Uh do you guys like to go up town?
You can come on to the Sugar Hill
Children's Museum. It's incredible. On
155th, the evening of September 25th,
you know what time we're
6 p.m. So come along out for Hispanic
Heritage Month. Thank you very much.
Thank you so much.
>> Wait, do you have any questions?
>> Question or two? Yes, sir.
>> Every year, wait for the mic, please,
Martin.
>> Every year we lose between five and 10
members.
uh actually in two years I among 10
others who will be turned out so we'll
be down about 20 people at that time so
half the board
>> uh various uh borrow presidents over the
years said oh yes I will add more people
during the year as you lose people it's
very difficult to run committees when
you have uh minus individuals
>> uh there. I know there's a there's been
a waiting list. You know, every year you
go through about 900 or so people to put
on the boards. There are people waiting
to come on. Yes.
>> So, if and when there is an open, we'd
appreciate a point. I believe one
opening on CB6. Sorry if I have that
wrong.
>> We we lost two people tonight.
>> I didn't know about it.
>> You found it.
>> Okay. So, that makes a three vacancies.
>> Is that correct?
>> Two.
>> Okay. one previously announced and one
announced tonight. Okay. Uh is that
person who's retiring here that I can
thank them for their service?
>> I hope not.
>> Send my hex.
>> Um I hear you. Uh we are already uh
because we are aware of one. We already
I believe have tapped someone for that.
Not sure if that's been publicly
announced yet, but we were all over that
one. And I'll make sure the team
expedites the second one. I hear you.
Quorum's tough. We don't need to make it
even tougher with vacancies. So, we'll
make sure we get you two good people
right away. Right.
Thank you so much, C6.
Did you have a question? You do the next
grand of applause.
Thanks, guys. Enjoy. Goodbye.
>> Okay, we'll try we'll go back to the um
public session. Uh Charles Coutino one
last time. Are you with us or are you
you are with us but are you able to um
enable your mic?
All right, we'll go on to the next
speaker then. Uh the next speaker is Pam
Zius also from Southern Area Community
who wishes to speak on the cannabis
application for 998 through 1000 first
app. Uh, Miss Zanzias, you have three
minutes to make your remarks. You may
begin now.
>> Can you hear me?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. Wonderful. Good evening, chair and
members of community board 6. My name is
Pamela Zzas, vice president of Sutton
Area Community. I'm here on behalf of
our neighborhood residents and local
businesses to express strong opposition
to the proposed cannabis dispensary at
998 and 10001st Avenue. There are
several clear and critical reasons why
this location is inappropriate and under
state law likely ineligible. One, the
proximity to a licensed school just
steps away at 357 East 55th Street is
the Monasuri School of New York. Under
New York State cannabis regulations,
specifically 9CRR119.4
Four, retail dispensaries cannot be loc
located within 500 ft of a school based
on standard block measurements and
available mapping. The proposed site
falls well within that prohibited zone.
Two additional nearby child care
facility, New York Kids Club. Direct
directly across the street from 998 1st
Avenue is New York Kids Club Sutton
Place, a wellestablished
daycare and preschool. Every weekday,
children and families actively use the
sidewalks and crosswalks in front of the
proposed dispensary location. While dayc
carees are not always clearly defined in
the statute, we strongly believe the
spirit and intent of the law are to
protect places where young children
congregate daily. Three, school bus
activity year round. This block is a
daily pickup and drop off zone for
multiple private schools and summer
programs throughout the year, especially
in the mornings and afternoons. School
buses stop directly in front of the
proposed location. Families rely on this
safe and accessible area as a designated
loading zone. The presence of a
dispensary in this exact location will
disrupt that pattern and pose a real
safety and environmental concern during
the school year. This location serves as
a pickup point for students attending
Riverdale Country School, St. Ignatius
Loyola School, the Hesshel School, and
others. In the summer months, children
attending Mohawk day camp and similar
programs are also picked up and dropped
off drop off tier. Number four,
community impact. This corner is a
central gathering space in our
residential neighborhood. It's
surrounded by homes, long-standing
merchants like Health Source Pharmacy
and Family oriented services. Locating a
cannabis dispensary at this intersection
is entirely misaligned with the needs
and character of the Sutton Place
community. We understand the need for
licensed dispensaries and support
responsible cannabis where appropriate,
but this location directly across from a
school, daycare, and active school bus
corridor clearly fails to meet the legal
requirements and community standards we
should all expect. We ur we respectfully
urge CB6 to vote against supporting this
application and to advocate that the
Office of Cannabis Management reject any
attempt to license a dispensary at 998
or 10001st Avenue. Thank you for your
time and for standing with us to protect
the integrity and safety of our
neighborhood. Thank you.
>> Thank you, Miss Anzas. Uh next on the
list is Ishan Gandhi, a resident of this
district uh who wishes to propose
uh who speak wishes to speak about
eating birds on East 54th Street between
2nd and 3rd avenues. Uh Ishan Gandhi,
are you here?
I don't see anyone. So we'll move on. Uh
the next speaker on the list is
Alexandra Marquez uh Oaks, a resident of
this district who wishes to speak to the
board about uh there seems to be a typo
here. The Sulk School, I think is what
they're trying to say. Um so
is that speaker here?
>> I see.
Yes.
>> All right. Uh Miss Marquez, you have
three minutes to make your remarks. You
may begin now.
>> Good evening and thank you members of
community board 6 for allowing me the
time to speak. I'm a parent at Sulk
School of Science, a small
high-erforming middle school. Sulk is
both academically rigorous and deeply
nurturing qualities that make it one of
the most sought-after public schools in
the city with a consistently long weight
list and a strong reputation built over
decades. Just before the summer break,
the superintendent
of district 2 introduced a proposed
merger between SulkQ and the
underenrolled Morton school in the West
Village. The stated reason was to comply
with the new class- size law. However,
based on what has been shared so far, it
is clear that no alternatives have been
seriously considered.
This proposal came as a shock to our
community. Sulkq has long been an anchor
in the district, a place where local
families know their children will be
challenged, supported, and inspired. The
proposed merger not only jeopardizes
that, but it also threatens to displace
a successful school from the very
community it serves. We are asking for
your support in protecting Salt's
future. We believe this school deserves
stability and ultimately a building of
its own, not a forced merger that puts
it its success at risk.
Thank you again for your time and your
attention to this important issue.
>> Thank you Miss Marquez for your remarks.
Uh we'll move on next to uh Shawa uh who
is a parent of a student at the Sulk
School as well and wishes to speak on
this same issue.
Uh is Shawa here? I see them online.
>> Yes.
>> All right. You have three minutes to
make your remarks. You may begin now.
>> Thank you uh CB6 for allowing um me to
speak and for hearing us out. I echo uh
my uh fellow parent um Alexandra's uh
words. Um this is against a merger that
has been proposed for Salt School of
Science with Morton on the west side. Um
in June we heard about the potential
merger initially not through the DOE but
through thirdparty sources and finally
when the news was shared by the DOE
there was no discrete plan of what were
the proposed steps to preserve what Salt
stands for. Like Alex has said has a
rigorous academic curriculum. It's a
nurturing small school with great
teachers, leadership, administration,
and a very, very tight-knit community.
Most importantly, SALK has been awarded
the blue ribbon award this year, and it
just received the National Education
Award of Excellence from Motive Awards.
What this merger or merger with any
school threatens is this community, the
school, the leadership, the
administration. Salt needs to be
celebrated. Salt needs to be built up
on. Salt does not need to be merged with
any school. What we are proposing is to
look at other avenues to see if salt can
get its own independent building and
grow where more kids and families can
benefit from.
What has also been done to support this
has been a petition filed by parents in
change.org which has currently received
more than 1,200 signatures. The children
have signed a petition which is going to
be submitted to the DOE and to the
current administration and the incoming
administration. We can use all support
from our community from our leadership
to prevent a merger of Sulkq with any
other school but to give what Sulk is
due its own independent building and a
chance to grow. so more kids and
families can gain from this. And again,
thank you for giving us the time and
hearing us out.
>> Thank you for your remarks. That that
concludes the speakers list tonight.
>> Great. Thank you everyone.
Um the minutes from the June 11th full
board meeting were distributed to board
members ahead of time by the board
office. If there is no objection, we
will adopt the minutes as drafted. Board
members, if you object to adopting the
minutes, you may raise your hand.
Seeing no objections, the minutes from
the June 11th full board meeting are
adopted. They will soon be available on
the CB6 website.
Uh chair's report. This month's minutes
show the attendance from this year's
full board meetings and how each
individual voted on the resolutions from
the June meeting. Um please take a look
at the most recent minutes that you were
sent.
So, you can go back to previous minutes
to see how how the board voted on any
resolution. And I'm not sure that people
realize this that it is public
information how you vote. So, um don't
be shocked if someone approaches you and
says, "Why did you vote that way?" Um
it's it's all it's all documented. And
also, um just wanted to point out that
unless you attend the meeting in person,
you don't count towards quorum. Uh,
everyone who's here realizes that and
realizes the benefit of coming together
as a group and unfortunately we can't
all do that always. But um, uh, unless
you unless you are not attending the
meeting due to a disability, you will
not count to quorum. Um, and it's very
important that we have a a quorum at our
committee meetings. Otherwise, we cannot
vote on the resolutions.
We we do go ahead and meet, but you
cannot vote. So
again, it's um this is more for the
people that aren't here probably and
certainly we know with a disability
people cannot attend. That's totally
understood.
Um it's been a busy summer. First thing,
our FDR proposal received a resolution
of support from Civotas early in the
summer. Um the burough president stole
my description of the Solar One um grant
opening.
Um but yeah, it's a great facility and
um great programs. We actually voted um
resolutions on it in support in 2008 as
well as in 2013. And we've already we've
always been a strong partner. I think
actually there's a resolution in front
of us tonight that allowed us to have a
champagne toast yesterday.
Um, another huge achievement on our
waterfront is the opening up of the
space at East 34th Street and the FDR.
This space will no longer be a parking
lot.
>> The East River is visible. Using this as
public space has been the goal of the
board for many years. And a huge thank
you to our past chairs, many who fought
very hard to get this to happen. Um, and
to Keith Powers who finally pushed us
over the edge, and the EDC, um, who
helped negotiate this as part of the
Spark agreement, and the parks
department who's going to take care of
the park in the future, uh, also
contributed some monies towards it. They
all work together to make this happen
and, um, there will be a celebration, so
stay tuned. We're not sure how we're
going to celebrate, but we will do that.
Um, so the community advisory committee
review of the casino applications is
underway. It closes September 30th. Um,
please submit your testimony to the New
York State Gaming Commission regarding
the proposed locations. Um, they have a
very robust website and you can make a
comment on any location in the city.
It's completely, you know, we're all New
Yorkers. We all have a say. Um their
their website covers everything about
all of these proposals.
Um all right. In accordance with section
3A of the CB6 bylaws, I've appointed an
elections committee. The elections
committee will be running the election
for CB6 officers that will take place in
November. For more details on the duties
of this committee and the election
process, please refer to the CB6 bylaws
found on the CB6 website.
I have appointed Marian Roth, Maya
Donahghue, and Omar Kershi to serve on
the elections committee. Miriam Roth
will will serve as the chair of this
committee. Miam will now say a few words
about the election process.
>> Very few
return engagement.
>> Yeah.
Um, if anyone is interested in running
for any position on the executive
committee, please submit your nomination
a self nomination or nomination of
another member to the board office at
info@c6.org
by Wednesday, September 24th. After this
date, nominations can only be made on
the floor at our October 2025 meeting.
If there are any questions, please
submit them to info@cb6.org
who will then forward all inquiries to
the elections committee. And again,
that's me, Maya, and Omar. Uh, as a
reminder, the committee serves to
oversee the technical process of the
election and to ensure compliance with
our board's bylaws. We are not
consultants for anyone's candidacy. And
there there are two questions that came
up often last year. So I just wanted to
try to help answer them and especi for
those who aren't familiar with the
process. Um each word office has a
one-year term. And so that means anyone
interested in any office right now can
nominate themselves or someone else. And
those positions just so you all have
them
are chair, first vice chair, second vice
chair, sec Oh, second vice chair twice,
sorry. Chair, first vice chair, second
vice chair, secretary, assistant
secretary, treasurer, and assistant
treasurer. So just know that every
position is available if you all would
like to and I encourage you to do so,
especially the new folks.
Thank you.
And just um to comment, we have two open
positions currently. We do not have an
assistant treasurer and we do not have a
second vice chair.
>> Question vice chair.
>> Second vice chair. That position is
empty.
>> Any questions?
We encourage everyone to run.
>> Yes,
>> we have a democracy.
>> Everyone. All of us. Yeah, anybody who
wants to.
>> Oh, dear Lord.
>> And one thing, once you do serve on the
executive committee, you will be asked
to join the executive committee meeting,
which is the Monday after full board or
Wednesday,
>> Wednesday after full board. Okay. Um, Be
Dishman will now give the treasures
report.
>> Thank you, Sandy. So, according to the
Crystal report for August 2025,
our budget for the fiscal year is
622,73,
which is only 1.6%
over what it was last fiscal year. And
let me remind everyone that last fiscal
year was extremely tight and with this
budget this year, we expect it to be
even tighter.
uh the amount that I just quoted of
includes our street fair money which is
140,311
and that money becomes even more
significant for us as the budgets get
tighter. So we do have a resolution that
says that money can be used for board
activities and certainly we used a
little bit of it this past fiscal year.
So we have encumbered already and
liquidated money of 237,526
and the largest percentage of that is
rent at 178,701.
So the unencumbered money uh that we
have left is 384,546
including the street fair money. So I
just want people to realize that the
office including uh Jesus and people
have to look very closely at what other
than personal services is spent on
because there really is not a lot of
flexibility in our budget and I just
want to make people aware of that. Sandy
I'll take any questions.
>> Do we have any questions for our
treasur?
>> No we don't have any. Thank you be
>> you're welcome.
So, we've now arrived at our committee
reports and resolutions. Members of the
public, please note that during this
section of the meeting, we only
recognize questions from members of the
board.
>> The CB6 staff emailed the digital ballot
to all members. Please click on the link
in your email that the office sent and
open the ballot, select your name from
the drop- down list, and vote on each
resolution when they are presented. Do
not hit submit until later in the
evening after the final resolution has
been presented and discussed. After you
have indicated all your votes on your
ballot, you can submit it. You will not
be able to submit the ballot unless you
vote on every resolution. If you plan on
abstaining, select abstain and note that
this will count as a negative vote in
the count. Final vote counts will be
announced after the second roll call. If
any part of our our voting procedure is
unclear, please raise your hand and we
will address your questions.
Okay, first up,
Anton Molner, chair of business affairs
and licensing.
This is what we get when we don't have
board meetings during the summer.
[Music]
>> Three separate meetings we had this uh
this summer. You know, business doesn't
stop. License applications don't stop.
DMT applications don't stop just because
of the summer. So, we do meet. Uh,
however, I'm going to try to make this
as painless, as quick as possible.
>> Um,
there there's like 573 of them.
[Laughter]
>> I think there's over a hundred.
>> We just bundle everything.
We don't know how you do it, Anton. We
don't.
>> We leave it up to you.
>> I'm asked to uh resolution the bundle of
numbers so we can get through this
fairly quickly. Uh June resolutions item
A. Uh this is for Monday alcohol events
program which actually already took
place. We have already said to the state
liquor authority
a notification that there was a
precision
um
done for this particular thing in the uh
committee itself. Uh I'd like to hear a
resolution model BCD
which are uh wine and liquor signing
licenses for three different entities.
There were no issues in terms of the
committee uh saying okay to these
>> move to bundle bundle
>> bundle I think we can bundle more
>> actually I'm actually wondering if we
can't bundle pretty much everything at
least of like kind even across months
like can we bundle all the sidewalk
cafes can we you know unless somebody
has an issue with something I want to
pull out. Can we do the roadway cafes,
the sidewalk cafe,
the liquor licenses?
>> I think that would be good for my start.
>> Yeah. Okay, sure.
>> I'd like to resolution the bundle EF
all the way through and these are all
sky block and roadway cafes. Some of
them require a lot of predictions, but
the committee did vote on them in
positive uh positive way. So, no issues
there.
>> Okay.
>> I think we're ready to bundle. Yeah.
>> Second.
>> Yeah.
>> To bundle.
Sorry, we can't we didn't catch
>> I was attempting to second the motion
that Ann made to bundle
>> to bundle everything that was the same
type of application. Is there anything
you specifically want to pull out?
>> Um
not leg resolutions.
>> Uh she was saying across all months
through Sure.
No, we can do it. I have just two
I'd like to bring to the board's
attention.
>> Okay. And
this is for the July resolutions.
Um
W and Sim
resolution recommending denial for
Sidewalk Cafe
for both Winsville and for pizza. Um
we did invite the principles for both of
them. they decided not to show up and
based upon that and their application we
felt it was best to deny their request.
They didn't have enough um interest in
showing up for the meeting u the
committee held that we're not going to
show interest in them u getting
half day license.
Um,
>> excuse me. Was was was that July W and
X?
>> Yes. Yes.
>> Okay. Thank you. Thank you, Anton.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. Do we have any objections?
>> Absolutely.
This includes everything including um
July Z and AA.
>> Yes.
>> Uh I have questions about um Z if I
could. Okay. the cannabis work. There's
a demand from the
uh work and the roadway cafe license
applications.
>> I think what we're trying to do is
address all the particular all the same
type of applications. So we'll do
cannabis after
>> the
not included in
sorry confusion. Yeah. But
>> like applications for sidewalk sidewalk
and roadway cafes.
>> Okay.
Okay. Um,
>> call the question.
>> Call the question. Okay. We can go ahead
and vote on all the sidewalk and um and
roadway cafes,
>> including the denials.
>> Including the denials.
Please go ahead and vote.
>> That leaves us with
Welcome
back to June resolutions. Um,
wine, beer, and cider licenses
for BC and D in June.
Let's see where else we have wine beer
and cider
in July.
And all of these were in favor?
>> Yes.
>> Okay, we'll go ahead and bundle all of
those
>> applications. One of your liquor
applications.
>> Okay, please go ahead and vote. Marty,
>> thank you. I believe K lists 10
together.
[Music]
I'm I'm sorry I didn't catch that.
>> I'm I'm K
as a vendor from the presses listed
together all one
>> uh for alterations.
Um they are all very timesensitive and
they're all um they were all uh no um no
objections. So the committee just put
them together and we send them off to
the SLA like that.
>> Okay, I think we're on to cannabis now.
>> And there were some questions on Y and
Zed.
>> Well, alterations.
>> Oh, sorry. Okay.
>> Okay. We have a bunch of them. No
objection. The alterations. alteration
may have to do with altering the liquor
license so that they could serve alcohol
on previously approved sidewalk or
roadway uh cafes.
>> Okay.
>> Call a question.
>> Okay,
>> please go ahead and vote.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. Can applications
Steuart had a question.
Please go ahead.
>> I have questions about the uh first of
all, did you said that the owners didn't
show up? Did anyone show up to represent
the owner or no one showed up?
>> We're talking about 98 and 100,000.
>> Correct.
>> First Avenue.
>> Yeah. He came before us not before that
and we didn't
review it because he had an issue with
um whether the license was new or
whether it was the transfer from a
cannabis site that he had in Queens.
So though we were um apprised of what he
really wanted to do, we didn't consider
it. Then the next month, the Office of
Canada's management decided to revamp
uh its rules regarding distance and that
put 998 and 1,000
uh in non-compliance with distance from
schools and houses of worship. Um
the uh applicant didn't show but he did
send us something saying
>> what was it I forgot
>> for for the second month the applicant
uh alerted us he would not be coming in
light of the
>> the change of interpretation of the
district requirements.
But he did he stopped short of fully
withdrawing his application. So so as
not to have nothing on the record, the
committee decided to proceed with a
resolution.
>> So yes, we did deny or um deny objection
to his application. Uh so we took
seriously what the community said
including the Celsius uh comments. Um
same thing for
um the count application for the
dispensary at 4132 second avenue. They
didn't show but uh just looking at the
distance applicate distance for the
applicant that would have formed out of
compliance with
uh the new rules by the office of pend
management. again to be on the record
send resolution of no objection to this
applicant.
>> Well, I just want to raise a concern
that you might be able to answer. Um I
presume that the um office candidates
management rules went through the formal
procedure uh and that the applicant at
the time that he invested any money um
or resources was following the existing
rules. if that's correct and then the
rules changed after he filed an
application and after he invested. I
think it's your concern that um it's you
know I mean this this has been a concern
and it has gone up to the governor's
office and the question is whether to
grandfather these applications andor
cannabis stores that are already in
existence. I think it was 144
uh stores that
foul with this new rule. So the question
is whether the law will be changed
whether be grandfathered is still up in
Albany.
>> Right. So, I don't know how far this
applicant went through the process, but
I would be concerned if the applicant um
found the signing lease and and has some
financial commitments as a consequence
of the representation uh of of the
government by the old
>> and an's going to respond to this
actually.
>> So, Stu, just so you know that we had
concerns about that as well. Um but we
had other issues with the application
um in terms of u transparency
during the application process and the
information that he was providing. So we
weren't entirely thrilled with the
application regardless of the OCM screw
up in proximity reporting.
So it it was not the only reason for our
you know for our objections.
>> It's interesting that in the Omatch
manage crossivity report
they did indicate a number of
applications that were sent to us that
they were not in compliance with the
distance requirements.
So sorry if you have a question just
>> so two two questions for me. Uh first
would you mind covering just explaining
the um the controversy around the
location exactly what the situation
there is and what what being changed and
corrected just uh for programs backing.
>> So why why it doesn't meet the 500 foot
rule? What what's the change that uh the
state has made to uh the 500 rule and
exactly why? What was the policy before
and what is it now changed to?
>> Wants to answer this, Anton, if you're
all right with it.
>> And she's in the back. It was a it was
basically a change between doortodoor
versus property to property line and the
legislation was written. It was
understood to be property line to
property line but that is not how the
rules for the proximity reports
uh like how how the GPS worked. So that
there were places that were legit
uh um you know door to door to door but
not property line to property line and
that's only relevant like these are
state laws but it's it's it like if
you're talking about you know Trumanburg
New York it's not there's not that much
of a difference but if you're in
Manhattan it is. And that's why that's
why half of the more than half of the
the locations that are impacted by this
are in Manhattan.
>> Does that make sense?
>> It does.
>> Um, next I had a a comment related to uh
Z. I believe that's the um
lost my place. Z's the um uh 998 1000
First Avenue.
>> Yes. See, see. Yes. Thank you. Uh so um
this is the second time we've had a
cannabis dispensary uh application for
the board where uh one of the basises of
our objection was that we liked the
business that was in that location and
we didn't want to see it replaced with a
cannabis uh dispensary. The other one
being um
stone uh 40th
45th 45th and second um I I I I don't
believe that uh the intention of the
community board review of uh of Canada
shops if the intent is for us to pick
and choose which stores we want in our
community. Uh, and I think we're
overstepping our
um our authority and our ability to
influence by um trying to select which
businesses we have in the community. We
don't generally have that power. If a
pharmacy wants to replace a convenience
store, a grocery store wants to replace
something else. That's not something the
community board has purview over. Uh,
and so I personally think it's
inappropriate for us to um oppose
cannabis locations because we like the
business that they would otherwise be
taking over the space for.
>> And see the discussion or watch the
meeting and come and see the discussion.
It makes it sound
a lot more casual than it is.
We go very much. Please Sarah.
>> Wait, wait. Let's uh
Sarah needs a microphone. M
>> thank you for letting me speak because
you know having been part of the
business affairs and licensing committee
I sit here you know I sit at the
meetings and I watch what's going on and
I will deal with the questions one at a
time I guess and they may not be in
order but with regard to the committee
thinking that we're going to decide
which you know doors we might keep and
not keep. That's not what we're doing.
We are looking at the applications as
they come in. We are very importantly
listening to the community that is in
that you know area where the shops may
be coming. Um, so I wouldn't say that's
not our focus and we spend a lot of time
with looking at the spaces and the
applications
with regard to,
you know, worrying or being concerned
about licenses or leases, I should say,
leases that these um applicants have
going on with, you know, the the
landlord
the one that we're talking about in this
case uh at the last month's meeting gave
us a little piece of paper with an
intention to rent this building and we
and thank you Ann because she is very
much tuned into all of these pieces we
asked him to please get a lease signed
for us. We need assigned leaks. That's
not unreasonable. And that's part of the
application process. He came back to us
this past month with the exact same
piece of paper that he had last month,
which was not formal and had a little,
you know, scribble of whatever it was.
But that's not appropriate for us to be,
you know, looking at. This is not a
legal document. So, you know, let's,
you know, look at the two issues because
yes, we did have our, you know,
representative that spoke to us, uh, on
Zoom.
Okay. You have to divide or separate the
new applications based on the new rules
out of, you know, management and those
that already have their license. And
they may have their license and it's
not, you know, they're not in the
distance because it's kind of you know
as Dan said the boundaries and as the
crow flies so you've got a lot of issues
there and those need to be taken care of
>> and in terms of leases the office of
Canada management is very clear that
it's a private transaction
it's between let's say Flintstone and
the landlord same thing in this
situation 198
8 1 Avenue. By the way, 1,000 is a
vacant store. 998 is the pharmacy and
um we took very seriously what the
community members said. After all, we
are representative of the community and
there was a lot of objection whether a
cannabis shop should be there at all.
Not withstanding it would may or may not
displace the pharmacy.
Okay. Can we Sorry, Marty.
>> Call the question.
>> I was going to just say if there's no
further discussion, let's please vote.
Please mark your ballots. Oh,
>> I want to make a quick comment.
>> Oh, sorry. Go ahead.
>> Yeah, I mean this has been a moving
target. um you know um especially given
the incompetence of the office of
management fund and we've been feeling
our way through this you know and trying
to understand what role our community
board plays uh in listening to the
community and it's not it hasn't been an
easy process and I just welcome people
to to attend our meetings because you'll
see as an said and Sarah said that we
agonize over these things it's not like
said we don't like this guy, you know.
So, I just hope that I'll be quiet with
a long agenda.
>> Thank you. Let's vote on these resol
these resolutions. Sir license.
>> Uh
resolution of objection
for new cannabis application retail
dispensary license uh at 436 second
Avenue and uh this falls in the same
situation we had. their prior
applicants. They don't abide by the
newly interpreted rules regarding
existence. Aside from the fact um
not only from schools and um houses of
worship but also other cannabis
applicants at the same time. Uh
so I'd like to call the question on the
candidates application.
>> Great. Please please mark their digital
ballots.
And I think that's it. Adam
and August item A as well. Um,
wanted to add some live music. We had no
problem with that. And
uh, MC Kips, which has the bar selling
wine and liquor, wanted to also sell
aside wine and beer, also wanted to sell
liquor. We had an update to show you
that
question.
>> Call the question. Okay. And do you have
a report, Anton?
Yeah, it's gonna take about half an
hour.
>> Okay.
>> Sorry. Sorry. Gloria Gloria has her hand
up.
>> Are we going? Are we done with
resolutions? We're still going through
>> We're done with the resolutions.
>> Question.
>> Oh, sorry.
>> 24 diner.
>> Which number is
>> the sidewalk cafe? Did you get the
reference? Um
21st
>> August.
What letter? What day?
>> N
>> N.
So, they're a 24-hour diner and we're
okaying a sidewalk cafe. So, I'm just
curious, is that sidewalk cafe open 24
hours?
>> No, it's not allowed.
>> No. No.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. All right. Anton, your report.
Well, interestingly, we received a
notification from DOT that
uh we cannot turn down
>> a request from an applicant for sidewalk
or roadway cafe simply because they
didn't show up at the meeting.
>> There had to be more
reasons than that. Uh second, we've
already talked about the confusion
uh with the cost management
uh on distance regulations.
Hopefully all those cannabis
um dispensaries that are currently
opening that are foul of the new
distance regulations will be able to
continue their business. Depends on the
governor. And next week we will be
meeting not to discuss applicants but to
talk about trying to more make our
committee more efficient and to educate
newer members on some of the rules and
regulations that we have to abide by for
SLA and do applications.
So, um, certainly other people are
welcome to attend that meeting, but it's
really meant to be for committee members
to give their opinions of how we can
speed up the process.
>> Great. Thank you.
Shorter than a bulk meeting. So, um,
>> actually down from four hours to three
hours.
>> You're you're up, Neil. Go ahead. We're
>> Yes.
parks, landmarks, and cultural affairs
fairs.
>> Hope everyone had a nice summer. We had
really good meeting. Uh 26 members of
the public were in attendance at the
office and we also had four board
members who attended Kevin O'Keefe Larry
Shorso
and Michael Cohen. So we appreciated um
you know their participation. So the
first resolution will it be the dog room
or
>> public restrooms is the first one.
>> Okay. So it be the restroom. Okay.
>> We're not going to put it on.
>> Do you want to put there are some
alterations to that? I don't know if
everybody saw the changes to the rest.
>> We just have one pulling it up now.
>> So we'll show that.
>> Yeah. Simple.
Is it
right that
Let me see if I can do full screen. Just
close the participants panel.
>> Yeah, close out.
There we go.
>> That should be better.
>> Okay. So, all that is fine. That's the
same. Can you just scroll down to the
bottom? The amendment part.
>> This does not have the amendments. I can
send it to No, it's
>> the one that's on the reso background.
Sorry about that.
No, read it out loud and mute.
>> Oh, okay. Sure.
Therefore, therefore resolve that
Manhattan board.
Sorry, it's all in red and it says
draft. So, it's tough to read. Result
that Manhattan Community Bo 46 supports
the proposal for a new public restroom
and North Brothers playground, but
requests that a more appropriate
exterior design be created to reflect
the location's character. So, that's the
>> Yes, you need the microphone. Sorry.
Uh I don't have a problem with the
amendment and in fact I think the whole
reszo is great. We need more restrooms.
We also need more water fountains and
you know they both take plumbing. I know
that Gail Brewer just got through
um
a res through the city council for money
or in the budget. I can't tell you
details, but for more money for water
fountains in and around parks and I
wonder if that's something that you have
kind of taken into account. I mean, is
it have not
>> does it have a water fountain? Is that
the question?
>> Water.
>> It does have a water fountain.
>> So,
thank you.
>> Thanks, Mark. Right outside.
>> Yeah.
>> Great.
>> Okay. Any more any discussion on Oh,
sorry, Jenny.
>> I had a quick quick question, Neil. So,
we had the conversation in the parks
committee. I was very supportive and the
exterior of the bathroom didn't come out
and not that I have a problem with it,
but I'm just wondering how it came that
this amendment was drafted. So we just
um we had uh looked at it again and just
you know general overview and um someone
I guess uh we did a comparison of what
it looked like to other um you know
restroom facilities. And so we just
thought that perhaps it would be closer
um you know it could have a better
design that could you know I guess like
a look as nice as the other restrooms
around the island. So that's all good.
Thanks. Thank you.
>> Kevin had a question.
>> Thank you. Just quickly to Ann's point
um you said water fountains. Uh it's the
mandate now for the parks department to
also have water bottle fillers. um not
just water bounds every time they put in
a new water uh unit which I think is
right.
>> Thanks Kevin.
>> Uh any more comments or can we vote on
this resolution? Okay, let's go ahead.
Please mark your digital ballot.
Okay,
>> we can move along to the end.
>> So,
there any questions about this one?
>> Yes.
>> Thanks. I was just wondering if this
proposed section for the smaller dolls,
is that within the existing footprint or
is it going to be kind of additional
space that's taken from the other parts
of the park?
>> Oh, it would be additional space, but
right now there's nothing going on in
that space. It's just open, that's all.
>> Okay. But yeah, but
>> no, but you know what I mean as in it's
not taking away like something from
playground or Kate can also add to that
because he's very familiar with it where
exactly it's located above your cell.
>> Yeah, it's actually idle. It was the
former dog park and now it is just
fenced off and it's growing mushrooms
and dirty and not being used and not
even allowed to be used.
Got it. Yeah. I guess my just question
would be like it could be used for
something else though then. Yes. Yes. If
it's not used for anything now. Okay.
>> Okay. If there's no more discussion,
we'll go.
>> We didn't have anyone else from the
community um state anything as and to
use it for something different. But we
did have 26 people who were very adamant
about adult run and they have 97 people
in total in their ranks who really want
adult run who are ready to volunteer. So
you know they came out in force.
>> Okay. Please let's vote on this
resolution. Rock your digital ballots.
And uh you have a report. Yeah.
>> Yes. Let me just report.
Okay, I'm happy right here. So, next
month um for the meeting we will have a
member of the community will present
about an update to a landmark building
in the district and so we look forward
to that. We'll also have some discussion
about uh the LPC landmark preservation
commission trying to you know say the
acronym so that everyone I remember I
had no idea what was going on DBC and
the only was the NYPD I think
>> um
>> so
so we'll have that and then I also I
just wanted to note that we do have
three new members of the committee. Um,
Daniel Bernstein, that was his first
meeting and he volunteered to take
minutes.
>> Yay, Daniel.
[Laughter]
>> Um, we also had Shua Yao.
>> Okay. She had really good questions.
And, uh, we also had Sandro Sherrod,
former board member, join the committee
as well.
>> Former board.
So they had three.
>> Okay, that's it.
>> Okay. Transportation. Jason from
>> Good evening. Uh tonight we've had a
resolution regarding redesign of the
ferry system. Um the main just right
quickly we're in support of the proposed
changes to fair system routes. Uh the
major changes affecting uh CB6 are that
the Rockaway road would be extending
from the Bronx to Rockway which means
that there will be access to Rockway
from 34th Street and Sky stops. Uh
whereas today that line only to Rockway
only runs from 11. Uh there's some other
in stops and the Rockways. Uh and
there's also a proposal to introduce
stops. Um so having fewer stops and uh
the east river route uh so that create a
more direct connection to 11 street uh
from street. Um and so yeah, we're uh
proposing to support the changes. Uh we
also made some comments uh and requests
and some just general feedback on them
including asking for half the day
and restrooms and social
>> the uh second wait for the mic please.
Sorry.
>> The second whereas written is somewhat
subjective rather than objective. You
can by eliminating 12 words and adding
one it becomes more fact-based.
Uh that being
>> a friendly amendment.
>> It would be a friendly amendment.
Um after the word after the 34th street
eliminating eliminating can be can be a
confusing and challenging
experience for intended passengers due
to just adding in healing. In other
words, you know, boarding a ferry on
East 34th Street includes long waits
between schedule, etc., etc. It makes it
fact based rather than some an opinion.
>> This is an amendment to your proposing,
right?
>> Okay.
>> What What line is this? Line 17
starting with the word can which is
after street.
>> Okay.
>> And and then on line 18 ending with the
word to as in due to and then including
the word includes
rather than
>> you're you're suggesting strike these
>> and put in the word includes.
The boarding a ferry at East 34th Street
includes long waits between scheduled
departures.
>> Okay.
>> Do we need to vote on that?
>> There's no if there's no great
objection.
>> If there's no objection, we can say it's
a unanimous approval.
>> Okay. All right. With that amendment,
was there anything else?
>> Okay. With that amendment, can we now
vote on this resolution, please? Oh, I'm
sorry. Sorry,
>> this is great. This new ferry map. I
just wanted to add another great thing
for CB6 that there's going to be a route
from 34th Street to Governor's Island.
So, in addition to
>> Great.
>> Okay. All right. Please vote. And um
since this is our last resolution, you
can now submit your digital ballot.
>> Uh have a brief report while you're
doing that. Uh over the summer, DRT
installed concrete extended curves on
Second Avenue between 20 and 18 Street.
Uh we had asked for this in April 2023.
Uh so it took a little while, but I'm
glad to see that uh finally implemented.
it was uh the concern around the
intersections that were frequently
parked in areas that were intended to be
daylight. So now uh car which is great.
Um and we heard from DOT last night that
um they will be implementing the
protected bike lane on Third Avenue uh
north of 15th Street that we passed a
resolution in support of uh before the
summer. They'll be implementing that
before the end of this will start
implementation before the end of this
month.
That's all. Thank you.
>> And I might add that um the meeting that
was proposed with the Murray Hill
Neighborhoods Association will happen.
It has not happened yet, but they are
working towards that. That was one of
the issues that came up at our June June
meeting. Um all right, health and
environmental kakad chair.
>> We're having our meeting tomorrow. We're
going to have a presentation from Dora
and then after that we're going to
discuss budget requests uh about the
budget request. I just want to thank
Marie for helping me out and walking me
through and answering a bunch of my
questions over the summer. So, thanks
for your help, Marty. And uh I also want
to we have two new members, Liz Bur and
Cat Valero. So, welcome to the
committee.
Okay. Land Juice and Waterfront, Gabe
Turzo.
Okay. We're going to have a very
interesting meeting coming up in
September. We're going to have a uh
presentation from the New York State
Department of Environmental Conservation
to discuss the city's water supplies and
aquafer health. Uh we we asked for that.
It's going to be very interesting. We're
may be on the schedule. It's
>> we're working on it.
>> We're working on it. Uh we're going to
be discussing the lost beds at the Mount
Si Beth Israel. We're going to have uh
something in the books, something
proactive. Uh so I highly recommend uh
anyone who's interested in that attend.
And then the the meat of the meeting is
going to be a discussion on the
faith-based affordable housing act. And
we're going to really get into the weeds
on this. Uh we're going to ask questions
like why religious institutions, why not
any nonprofit? uh exactly which housing
rules are being fasttracked and how and
if these processes are so vorous, why
don't we fasttrack all housing
applicants? Uh so we're going to look at
all of this. Uh we also have a new
member who might be taking minutes here,
Daniel Bstein.
So I I encourage everybody who has any
questions about this to attend or if you
can attend and if you're curious about
anything particularly the the housing
act email me and I will try to address
it in the meeting. Thank you. Any
questions?
>> So uh the the waterfront greenway
recent years it's just still a mess. You
can't there's a bin you still can't
cross it. last time went there. Any kind
of update because uh you know it's how
long is it going to be? It's uh we have
to wait till like 2015 because this is
New York. This is they're going to build
they're going to build an outer board
walkway around
similar to what they did from uh 53rd
Street to the uh 59th Street Bridge
connecting to the EPA going up. They're
going to be building a outboard walkway
that'll be over the water that'll bypass
the pinch point.
>> Yeah. When is another story?
>> When is there another story? But I I've
spoken to uh the construction people who
had finished with Susco Park and I asked
them specifically about that and they
told me what they were going to be
doing. It's
>> like 7.3 times a day. I hear why is the
west side so nice and the east side is
just trash and I don't know
question DGC has this on the books and
we can reasonably conservatively expect
it by the end of the decade
>> is a huge barrier
>> it actually is not
>> we're not the barrier at No, leave it
alone.
>> And yeah, let let's let's not we're
working on it. We're trying to get the
the east side to be as good as the west
side. So, let's let's move on. Um,
budget affairs and budget and government
affairs. Rashma Patel.
>> Um, thank you, Sandy. Um, we are having
our monthly meeting this month on um,
September 30th, which is actually our
October meeting, and that is a public
meeting on the budget. And um I'm glad
to hear uh Rupal that you guys are
discussing budget requests at your next
meeting. If everybody can have their
request in um before the 30th um that
would be great because after that we
can't add or change anything after the
public meeting because we're going to
start preparing our submission. Um and
that's it. And welcome to the new
members. Uh we have two new members on
our committee. I uh because I'm in
transit, I cannot remember the names
unfortunately right now. But
>> okay, that's okay.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, we're on to housing and
homelessness. Alec Milit.
>> Uh so on our meeting on Monday, we're
going to introduce the new members of
the committee. I believe that it's four,
maybe three, four. Um, and as an update
for the board, we also submitted over
this summer.
So hopefully we're going to have a plan
to come and analyze
um
senior housing, senior specific housing.
It was discussed a bit um in committee
meetings in the spring. So stay tuned.
>> Okay. Youth and education. Katie Landa.
Okay, she's on.
>> Hello. Um, so the our first meeting
isn't until October 28th. And I'm a new
chair. We also have uh new members Kate
Kennedy and Liz Burr. And I'm hoping um
Kyle Thide will be joining us as as
well. And um we'll be uh at the first
meeting uh developing our agenda. I'll
be reaching out to uh members
individually before that meeting because
of the the lag. And it looks like we
have uh a first issue that was brought
to us tonight to work on this the sock
school.
>> Great. Okay. Public safety and
sanitation. Stu Desert. Uh we didn't
meet this month and because of the
holiday we may not meet next month. Uh
so we have declared an extended summer.
[Music]
>> Yeah. Okay. Great. Um so board members
if you have any old or new business to
state please raise your hand.
>> Okay seeing none um Jesus will now
conduct the second roll call. Before I
begin, if you have not submitted your
ballot, please do so now. Uh I off the
bat I see Gabe, you have not submitted
yours.
>> I'm calling folks out.
>> You are on blast.
>> Uh Daniel Bernstein, they're long, I
know. So get started now. Um I'll start
from the from the Z's this time so no
one feels neglected. Uh Shuya Zhao
>> here. Thank you. David Woods
>> here.
>> Thank you. Sarah Whittington,
>> present.
>> Thank you.
>> Jerry Weinstein is absent. Julis Vera is
absent. Patalero
>> present.
>> Thank you. Gabe Tzo here. Thank you.
Mark Thompson is absent.
Letty Simon,
>> I'm here.
>> Thank you.
Uh, Lubine Sadiki
>> present.
>> Thank you. Sandro Sherrod.
>> Thank you. And Seligman,
>> thank you. Larry Sh is absent. Michael
Anroe is absent. Mariam Ralph
>> here.
>> Thank you. Omar Careshi
>> Thank you. Will Perry. Thank you. Steve
Perez is absent. Rishma Patel.
>> Rashma seems to be off.
>> No.
>> Okay. Um Kevin O'Keefe
>> present.
>> Thank you. Rich Mintz is absent. Alec
Milletch
>> present.
>> Thank you. Sandy McKe
>> Thank you. Anton Melner
>> here.
>> Thank you. Uh Sandre Liftoff
>> Thank you.
>> One quick interruption. Um, Kyle, don't
forget to submit your ballot.
I see.
>> Okay. Katie Landa,
>> present.
>> Thank you. Kate Kennedy
>> here.
>> Thank you. John Keller
>> present.
>> Thank you.
Rupal Kakat
>> here.
>> Thank you. Paige Judge
>> is not here, I guess.
>> Okay. Uh, Rabia,
>> not here.
>> And Gloria H,
>> present.
>> Thank you. Justin Goldberg is absent.
Eric Goldberg,
>> thank you. Jason Fromitz,
>> present.
>> Thank you. Barack Freriedman,
>> Thank you. Robert Farpan,
>> present.
>> Thank you. Maya Donahghue, thank you. B.
Disman,
>> present.
>> Thank you. Stu Desesser,
>> here. Thank you. Jim Collins is absent.
Liz Burr,
>> present.
>> Thank you. Daniel Bernstein,
>> Thank you.
>> Elie Barroso,
>> thank you. Martin Barrett,
>> present.
>> Thank you, Neil Barkley.
>> Thank you, Kyle Thigh.
>> Kyle,
and we still need your ballot.
Okay. All right. Um, last call for these
ballots.
>> You forgot me.
>> Uh, Tanya Arias, I'm sorry,
Tanya Aras. Good
>> from Miami.
>> All right.
We won't hold that against you.
>> Okay.
>> Reason.
All right. Um,
one, two, three. Final call for the
ballots. I will call them. Once I call,
you can't submit it anymore.
Okay.
Um,
there are a lot of them. So, I'm not
going to go through each and every one.
I am just going to tell you if there
were some that did not pass. So, I need
to go through
And so far, all of them seem to have
passed, but it's going to get through
all of them. They're all in separate
tabs. Forgive me.
>> About 50 of them.
>> Yes.
So far, I don't see a rejected one. I've
still got a few more to click through.
>> All right, all of them have passed. We
will get the precise details in next
month's minutes.
>> Okay. Yes. And how everyone voted.
Great. All right. Um, sorry, I have one
last thing I'm supposed to say here. Um,
if there are no objections, we will
adjourn the meeting. See no further
business, the meeting is adjourned at
8:44. Thank you all.
>> Great meeting.
>> Excellent.
>> Thank you.
Belle meeting at 6:30 tomorrow.